hello everyone and welcome to another
brilliant game from round six of the
2022 vhs olympiad it is a game that has
to be inspected with uh in great detail
in order to be appreciated to its
fullest potential as you know many
secrets are hidden in this game uh and
uh board one for australia uh is played
by anton smirnov board one for norway of
course by world champion magnus carlson
uh there is quite a bit of a
rating difference 2600 versus 286 but um
as is usually the case when someone
faces uh magnus carlsen uh but uh and
smirnoff is an incredibly deadly
opponent uh already uh in two olympiads
that he played in the tromso olympia of
2014 and the bach will impede of 2016 he
went undefeated uh with incredible
scores in rome so he had seven and a
half out of nine and in baku he had
eight and a half out of ten so those are
some incredible results
but now he has white uh he's playing
against magnus and the magnus chooses
the weirdest opening possible uh to try
and uh you know grab a win in this game
so let's uh enjoy the game uh there is
quite a lot to see uh so uh anton has
the white pieces and he opens with e4
and what does magnus play against this
well he goes for knight to c6 the names
of edge defense
which is a weapon used by people who
don't really understand chess and by
people who understand chess better than
everyone else so unless you are in one
of those two categories you cannot you
can never play the names of each defense
so here knight to f3 uh we have d6 and
now pawn to d4 why it says all right you
are playing weird moves i'm just gonna
you know grab the full center develop my
minor pieces uh what everyone should do
in chess knight to f6 attacks the e4
pawn and of course anton defense knight
c3 we have g6 magnus preparing to fiance
to his dark square bishop and h3 now
stopping bishop to g4 we have bishop to
g7 bishop to e3 and now magnus castles
and a nice queen to d2 uh preparing to
castle queen side also at some point we
might trade off a carlson strong dark
square bishop so here a6 by magnus and
the bishop to d3 and now magnus strikes
in the center with e5 we have a trait
here captures captures uh sorry not with
the pawn knight recaptures knight
recaptures and d captures on e5 uh smear
of a castle's queen side and here uh
there are a couple of games where bishop
the e6 was played but interestingly the
top move recommended by the engine is
pawn to b5 and this is what magnus plays
so it is now as of movie 11 that we have
a completely new game so what did magnus
get from his weird opening choice
playing the names of which defense well
he got a very very
uh interesting position with castles on
opposite sides of the board so it's
gonna be a race it's gonna be an
attacking game and uh well he's
definitely risking a lot for his uh for
his country of norway to grab a full
point here uh but it's also a great
opportunity for smirnoff to take down
world champion magnus carlsen so let's
see how he continues he starts by
advancing on the king side pawn to g4
and magnus plays c6 uh just uh
solidifying on the queen side we have f3
and now bishop to e6 putting pressure on
this um a2 pawn so if the knight moves
we can simply capture it and uh it's
always a question do you play king v1 do
you not play king b1 we've seen what
happened to abdusathrov in the previous
game by not linking to g1 or rather king
to h1 against
hari krishna
but here he decides to commence the
attack at once so pawn to h4 and the
magnus goes queen to a5
with a3 uh here you could uh go for a
race with h5 but he chooses the first
play a3 it's a nice trick if you want to
prevent black from playing b4 in this
position and in similar positions
because if b for now you can just move
the knight and now of course black
cannot capture as the queen would hang
so here we have rook f2b8 magnus again
prepares to push and now comes bishop to
c5 and this uh
seems uh like a move that um well he
just respects magnus a bit too much you
know it is of course hard not to respect
magnus but here you have to play h5 and
you have to fight
after bishop to c5 yes he stops the b
form but now uh he just allows the
magnus to play h5 and now he will no
longer be able to play h5 himself so
bishop to d6 attacks the rook and now
magnus plays rook to b7 we have king to
b1 finally the the prophylactic move
comes and rook to d8 now aligning the
rook with carlson uh with
asminov's queen on d2 we have bishop to
b4 attacking the queen and queen to c7
and now now you really don't want to see
c5 on the board so here knight to e2 if
c5 then we can play bishop a5 and win
some material here so magnus plays rook
to d7 and now bishop to c5 stopping this
c5 push and now magnus just placed h
captures on g4 we have knights to g3 you
don't really have an option here you've
decided to give up some material but you
will get your h5 moving so g captures on
f3 by magnus he still waits with the b4
push and pawn to h5 now we have queen to
d8 now aligning the rook and queen with
that queen on d2
and the h captures on g6 with f captures
and g6 and now queen to g5 so who is
who's really attacking here we have king
to have seven magnus defends the uh g6
pawn with the king you could also do it
with the with the bishop uh but i think
magnus is just testing um smart enough
to see what he will do because
this allows smirnoff to
play a move that might not be all that
spectacular it looks spectacular but it
might not be and i think that with king
to f7 magnus is just on such a different
level that he maybe played this to try
and invoke uh
the move as here you really don't have
uh
anything better than retreating with the
queen queen e3 or queen that to d2 and
then magnus would try and figure out
some different sort of plan let's say
king g8 if you repeat then bishop to f7
defend it like this and then at some
point uh finally push b4 but here we
have knight to f5
and what's the the idea behind the
knight sacrifice can it be accepted yes
it can but you have to really brute
force calculated uh and magnus decides
against it maybe he thought he was too
risky uh accepting this but i will show
it as it is possible for our good friend
the engine to you know just brute force
this uh if you if the knight is accepted
g captures an f5 then uh you have a
variety of choices but your main one
seems to be rook to g1 going after the
bishop here and now king the e8 now the
bishop is defended now you play queen g6
check rook to f7 and just nicely
defending and now rook the h7 offering a
rook to be able to capture the bishop
here but now bishop the f8 this is how
you defend you put more pressure on the
rook
with the knight and with the rook so
rook the h8 now puts pressure on the
bishop here on f8 and here magnus would
have king to d7 and now you are out of
the woods if pawn captures an f5 bishop
to d5 and that's it white is officially
out of ammo
and there is really no
no good move to be attempted here so
that's how you refute it but after
knight to f5 magnus played knight
captures an e4 it is uh the other way to
play this now the queen is attacked and
also you cannot capture the knight
because of rook captain d1 and the
bishop covers a2 you will get checkmated
so knight to h6 with check we have
bishop captures an h6 queen captures and
now bishop back to f5 uh guarding that
knight here and asking what do you play
here and there really isn't all that
much you can play now with white for
example if queen to h7 uh we can just
play king f6 and if you go queen to h
for wichita king e6 and there are no
more useful checks uh that that's just
it black wins however uh you can play
king the a2 uh which is what smith have
tried the best way to play this is rook
to c1 but it's i mean who plays this so
king the a2 was tried uh but now we have
queen to g8 this is a beautiful move by
magnus as it aligns the black queen with
the white king on a2 so here bishop
capture sunny for uh bishop characters
and now avoiding the rook trade with
rogue detail e1 attacking the bishop and
now uh ladies and gentlemen feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that wins the game for magnus while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail and a great discovery is about
to be uh well discovered and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course king to f6 check
beautiful uh just opening up a discovery
with the king towards the white king
and this is well just incredibly
important so congratulations to everyone
who found this it's the only winning
idea and to show you why it's the only
winning idea let's say okay your bishop
is defended you play bishop f5 the
problem is okay you're gonna play b3 now
no more discoveries can be played and if
king to f6 now hoping to get rook to h7
in that's not happening queen h4 check
and black is lost king e6 we're gonna
play rook captures on e5 a beautiful
rook sacrifice king captures rookie one
check king to d5 and now queen to d4
will be checkmate so this is what lurks
uh in the vicinity if you are not
careful so magnus spots this and he
plays king to f6 with check now this is
not to deliver check check is only used
as a tool or rather as a as a tempo
provider to allow rook to h7 to be
played without wasting time so here b3
blocking check and now rook to h7 and
now the white queen no longer has access
to the h4 square and that is a big
problem queen to e3 now again putting
pressure on the bishop and if the bishop
moves on the e5 pawn but not just the
rook captures um
on h1 uh we have rook chapters on h1 and
now queen to d5 defending the bishop
here we have king to b2 and now rook to
d7 just uh
getting everything into the attack we
have rook to h8 trying something
but it's very hard magnus is now just up
three pawns the attack failed and the
pawns will prevail so bishop to f5 we
have rooked their fate with check and
now just rook to f7 we have rook to e8
and here queen to e4 offering a queen
trade queen to d2 and now king back to
g7 not allowing any more tricks not
allowing queen to h6 or anything so here
bishop to f2 stopping the past pawn but
now just queen to e2 and he was in this
position on move 41 or rather on move 40
upon reaching time control that anton
smino resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so uh
incredible game by both of them uh
really took a lot
this brilliancy of playing king to f6
check and allowing those rooks to
connect along the seventh rank uh
basically here you resign as you have to
trade queens otherwise you're going to
lose even more material and after you
trade queens it's just too easy to win
this rook captures and e5 goes after the
pawn but now you just play bishop g4
defend your pawn attack the dark square
bishop on f2 bishop p1 rook f1 now after
the bishop moves you're going to start
bringing the king into the game
and that's it you are up two pawns of
course this is completely winning both
of them know this so there is no point
in continuing this game
so truly an incredible king the f6 move
we can uh check it out one more time
after rook d to e1 just an incredible
king to f6 check i mean when was the
last time you've seen such a move
allowing rook to h7 i mean this is this
truly spectacular chess and even though
i like like we've shown magnus could
have seized the upper hand much much
sooner in the game uh he allowed uh
therefore be some chance for for
smirnoff to fight but uh uh
you know the the there was just the
problem of this king to f6 move that
magnus found
uh so yeah uh what does this mean for
for magnus carlsen well it means that
he's a one step closer to his goal of
reaching 2900 classical rating he is now
on five and a half out of six as he
played all of the games in norway chess
in the the six rounds that were played
uh however for the team norway it's not
as great as both uh tari and hammer lost
their games on board two and three
but uh you know
what you're gonna do you could you can
just win your own game and hope that
your your teammates win as well and
these are the uh top uh top uh uh 39
players in the world these are the only
players rated above 2700 so you can see
carlson is now on plus two and a half uh
which is pretty incredible five and a
half out of six and only two and a half
rating points so he's getting closer to
that 2900 rating but
very very uh slowly so now some other
players that are they're increasing
their rating you can see anish uh uh
plus six and a half you can see
mamidarov plus six almost plus five out
of nine uh hari krishna plus nine that's
also very uh pretty incredible as he's
you know now in the world's top twenty
goku of course we keep mentioning him
every day as he wins all of his games
he's the only player on six out of six
now look at him 27 19.3 he's up 20
points then uh diac with nine and a half
also pretty incredible uh he's a number
number 31 in the world and those are the
only positive players above 2 700.
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and a little bit of extra
info regarding the situation uh with
with uh you know and norway and the
ratings and whatnot so i hope you
enjoyed that as well i would like to
thank uh esmond alden jacob tobias derek
king felix daffo and casey vance for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad uh until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
tomorrow don't be surprised i will be
filming uh from a different venue for a
couple of days
see you soon